hey guys it's mkbhd back with an hd
video review of the audio technica ath
m50s my self-proclaimed best headphones
for under 200 bucks
period so you know these have to be good
and if this video gets 800 likes i will
give away a pair on twitter so you can
view that link below so let's get
started
so right away you can see the m50s are a
sleek high quality pair of headphones
and they feature a really solid build of
mostly metal and a little bit of plastic
but for the price point like i said if
you're looking for sub 200 headphones in
terms of build quality this is
absolutely the way to go so starting
from the bottom and working our way up
we have a three and a half millimeter
gold plated headphone jack with a really
really solid build don't see that
breaking anytime soon connected to this
jack is a 1.2 meter or four foot cable
and that cable is also coiled so that
makes it more like six feet so you can
reach it around behind a desk or
something over at the other end of the
cable it's the star of the show it's the
m50s themselves looking good so starting
off with the build quality these
headphones are top notch which is an
awesome segue because these have little
notches on the sides that allow you to
adjust the size of the headphones so
that's perfect if you have a gigantic
dome you can still rock these or if you
have a tiny skull these will work for
you too also you can see these are
adjustable in all kinds of ways so you
can literally have a pterodactyl-shaped
head and these will still create a seal
wonderful oh and unlike some other
headphones in this budget this pair is
ridiculously durable so major props to
audio technica on this one well done and
another thing i like to talk about in
headphones is comfort and this is one of
the again top of the line for this
budget it's really really soft and all
the parts are flexible enough to fit to
your pterodactyl-sized or whatever sized
head and yet they do all this while
still being able to fold up and fit in
this handy dandy carrying pouch thing
but what's a headphone review without
word on how they sound well that'll be
pretty stupid so we're going to check
that out right now first we have to get
some music on
uh there we go perfect let's listen to
some gaga first
all right so i'm just going to tell you
right now these headphones are flat out
amazing pun intended that that was that
was intended the frequency response is
flat and amazingly accurate i would
happily pay 200 250 dollars for these
headphones but as you can see by the
link in the description i only paid 160.
even if you have the most crazy musical
tastes any of the music that i'm
listening to right now sounds amazing
the lows are very very deep they're not
overpowering at all the mids are very
well balanced and the highs are
extremely nice they sound just as fine
with the mids and the lows as any other
hives i've ever heard so this is one
well-balanced pair of headphones and i
couldn't recommend anything else if you
have a 200 budget this is the pair of
headphones you need to buy
this is also going to earn the i think
the third ever mkbhd 10 out of 10
product rating so you believe me if you
if you have any problems with these
headphones come to me and uh by the way
if this video does get 800 readings i do
want to see a video review from the
person that wins them either way thanks
for watching this video mkbhd signing
out
peace
[Music]
laughs